der bundespräsident besucht heute die
kaserne und den truppenübungsplatz der
us streitkräfte im nordbayerischen
grafenwöhr wir nehmen dies zum anlass um
uns die us-unterstützung für die ukraine
genauer anzusehen dazu begrüße ich im
studio den sicherheitsexperten joachim
weber guten morgen bei phoenix guten
morgen für furore sorgt in der ukraine
das mehrfach raketen abwehrsystem
heimers das vor allem von den usa
geliefert worden ist was kann dieses
system was kann dieses system im moment
an der front erzielen er ist es ein
hochprozentiges waffensystemen was sehr
stark in die tiefe wirken kann also mit
den raketen die ukraine wohl haben circa
80 kilometer das ist natürlich sehr weit
ins hinterland wo man seine depots seine
logistik stützpunkte angelegt hat und
die können mit diesem system sehr
präzise getroffen werden mit diesen
raketen und das ist für die russen
schmerzhaft 50 bis 60 solcher systeme
brauchen wir sagt der
generalstab der ukraine was weiß man
denn darüber können wir keine sich die
hoffnung machen dass diese zahl
tatsächlich geliefert wird also ob sie
so viel wirklich bekommen werden wird
man sehen bisher haben sie ja zirka ein
halbes dutzend die zahlen gehen ein
bisschen auseinander das ist natürlich
zu wenig um ein game changer zu sein
diese systeme müssen auch gewartet
werden sie unterliegen auch natürlich
gegenangriffen durch die russen das wird
nicht ewig dauern bis die ersten von
denen kaputt geschossen sind wenn ich
dann ist natürlich bei 56 stück schnell
ein ende erreicht aber wenn man ein paar
dutzend von den hätte könnte es durchaus
ein stück weit zum game changer werden
nun besucht der bundespräsident ja die
amerikanischen truppen in nordbayern
auch um ihnen zu danken und sie in
gewisser hinsicht auch zu ehren wie
beurteilen sie in den letzten 140 tagen
das engagement der amerikaner in europa
aber vor allem in der ukraine ja das
engagement der amerikaner ist
entscheiden die europäer haben wir zwar
auch einiges getan aber bei weitem nicht
so viel wie die usa die usa sind der
anker pfosten sozusagen der ukrainischen
verteidigung ohne die amerikanischen
waffenlieferungen
ohne die unterstützung der usa auch mit
satellitenaufklärung nachrichten und
dergleichen über russische bewegung wo
russische ziele und dergleichen mehr der
läuft ja ganz viele auch hinter den
kulissen würde der ukrainische
widerstand zusammenbrechen die usa sind
der kosten welche signale kommen denn
jetzt mal unabhängig von der politischen
situation und den wahlen den
zwischenwahlen im november anstehen aus
washington wird jetzt sozusagen
kontinuierlich so weitergehen es sieht
alles danach aus man ist sich in
washington wie auch in vielen
europäischen hauptstädten im klaren
darüber dass ein sieg russlands die
europäische sicherheits ordnung so
zerstören würde in ihren grundfesten
dass wir uns an einer welt wiederfinden
würden in der wir wahrscheinlich nicht
gerne leben wollen also ein totaler
zusammenbruch der ukraine muss aus
westlicher sicht unter allen umständen
abgewendet werden und ich glaube die
amerikaner werden aus ihrer sicht alles
dafür tun um dieses ziel zu erreichen
osch/moskau com jahr regelmäßig
warnungen auch jüngst in dieser woche
kam es von dort eine warnung so nach dem
motto man würde unter umständen durch
diese unterstützung zur kriegspartei
werden und aus dem
verteidigungsministerium in moskau kamen
die warnung das ist vielleicht dann
irgendwann auf eine konfrontation hinaus
laufen könnte also zwischen russland und
den usa das würden sie als propaganda
bezeichnet oder wie ist es zu bewerten
als reine propaganda würde ich es nicht
bezeichnen die mir das schon sehr ernst
wir müssen ja die situation sehen dass
wir uns seit ende februar hineintasten
denn das was immer gerade noch geht
nicht unter sind wir inzwischen recht
weit fortgeschritten es kann
wahrscheinlich unter dem druck der
russischen angriffe auch nicht anders
sein aber das ist nicht ohne risiko und
insofern kann ich auch nur an alle
appellieren die sagen ja das müssen das
militärische austragen wir müssen
natürlich das politische element ständig
im auge behalten und welche politische
element gibt es sind ganz ganz schwierig
weil offenkundig mit tutti niemand
verhandeln möchte und und der im moment
auch noch gar nicht verhandlungsbereit
scheint das ist und bleibt ungeheuer
schwierig diesen angerichteten
flächenbrand wieder zu einem ende zu
kriegen wollen die ukrainer nicht
verhandeln die wollen dass die russen
verschwinden aus ihrem land präsident
selensky hat diese woche erklärt es wird
eine offensive gestartet oder es ist
eine gestartet worden im süden richtung
carson möglicherweise richtung
welche erfolgsaussichten hat diese
offensive offensive also zunächst einmal
ist völlig richtig dass die ukraine
versuchen die erlangte von dem aggressor
wieder zu befreien und ihr land zurück
zu bekommen dagegen können wir auch
nicht haben ja die erfolgsaussichten
denen sie fragen die sind schwer
abzuschätzen denn die russische
überlegenheit dann artillerie an
schweren waffen ist nach wie vor
natürlich gegeben dass konnten 56
raketenwerfern nun auch noch nicht
grundsätzlich ändern und insofern wird
das wahrscheinlich von der ukraine mit
hohen verlusten erkauft werden wir
werden sehen wer da die oberhand behält
jetzt steuern wir auf den hochsommer zu
auch in der ukraine hohe temperaturen
aber gedanklich müssen sich ja die
general stehe vor allem in kiew schon
darauf vorbereiten dass ist demnächst
wieder herbst und winter wird ich lese
immer dass die ukraine eine gewisse
furcht hat vor dem winter weil das
möglicherweise dann vorteile für die
russen bringt warum ja das wird man
sehen wie man es mehr vorteile bringt
aber man kann in der tat bei
sommerwettkämpfen so belastend dass
thermisch vielleicht wird die soldaten
auch sein mag aber aber dann kommt der
herbst und die bewegungen der truppen
werden buchstäblich einfrieren nach und
nach der winter ist ja auch harte diesen
regionen und dann wird man sehen wer
besser seine truppen wieder versorgen
und umgruppieren und nach führen kann
und da sind natürlich die russen als
seinen start mit fast unbegrenzten
mengen an schießt zeug und 140 millionen
leuten wahrscheinlich besser in der lage
ihre verluste zu ersetzen die ukraine
seien 40 millionen folge und von denen
sind ein paar millionen jetzt auch noch
außer landes geflüchtet und die
wirtschaft ist in großen teilen zerstört
oder liegt danieder also die zeit wird
nicht unbedingt für die ukraine spielen
es sei denn sie bekommen geradezu
unbegrenzt waffenlieferung aus dem
westen tag 140 des krieges russlands
gegen die ukraine herr weber ich sage
danke für diese analysen danke dass sie
heute morgen bei uns im studio bank sehr
gern